تهديد قوه السلاح اضطرت هذه العائلات
التسعه الى ان ترحل من بيوتها في منطقه
القنوب شرق الخليل وتستقر هنا في بريه
سعير يعيشون في خيام وفي ظروف استثنائيه
وصعبه في ظل الاجواء الشتويه البارده ندخل
الى هذه الخيام لنتعرف بتفاصيل اكثر على
حياه الناس هنا احنا المستوطنين بنعاني
منهم كثير قبل الحرب هذه لان حطونا يعني
في منطقه الجنوب اللي احنا ساكنين فيها
اللي هي ارضنا يعني
حيطين المستوطنين هذا حماه التلال ومعهم
غنم من كل الاتجاهات من الشرق ومن الغرب
ومن
الشمال الحين في خلال الحرب هذه زادت
اعتداءاتهم علينا وزاد شرهم
باتجاهنا ثالث يوم الحرب اللي هو ت
ع اخذوا غنم محمد عبد الفتاح شلال ده زلمه
قربتنا هوت وابنا هم اولاده يعني حوالي
200 راس واحرقوا بيوتهم احنا بعديه ظلينا
مستمرين لغايه
1111 واجوا علينا على بيوت نداهم يوم واحد
الشهر 1111 يوم الاربعاء اجوا علينا المسا
بشكل
يعني جنونه وجم علينا على البيوت واطلعو
من بيوتنا غصب
عننا تركنا كل شي ورانا ما اخذنا ولا شي
معانا بيوتنا ودورنا دشر كهوف ونا بيار
ونا علف
للغنم طاقات شمسيه وتنكات والله عشتنا ما
بتصر صديق واحنا متامل ان شاء الله الا
نرجع ل ارضنا بعد ما تنتهي الحرب ان شاء
الله الا نرجع لها واحنا هذه يعني وقت
يعني بدنا نتحمل ه الفتره اللي مرينا فيها
لان والله فتره
عصيبه اذا شكرا لك ابراهيم كما يقول على
امل العوده الى بيوتهم والى منازلهم في
منطقه القنوب شرق الخليل تبقى هذه
العائلات تعيش على هذا الامل واليقين
بانها عائده الى بيوتها والى منازلها رغم
اعتداءات المستوطنين المتواصله والمستمره
ما قبل السابع من اكتوبر وما بعده منتصر
نصار الجزيره بريه سعير شمال شرق الخليل